the kind of things that can get you in
trouble on a campus these days would be
hysterical if they weren't so tragic hi
I'm Ted baliker with Reason TV and today
I'll be speaking with Greg Luciana
lukianov his president of fire the
foundation for individual rights in
education briefly what is the mission of
fire fire was founded back in 1999 to
defend and sustain individual rights on
college campuses primary among those is
freedom of speech but also we work with
academic freedom due process freedom of
association etc but I'd say the majority
of our work is freedom of speech work
the idea of the university is so noble
the free marketplace of ideas and so on
what's the reality of the university
environment these days prior to working
at fire if you were to tell me that I
would deal with cases that are absurd
and outrageous dealing with censorship
on campus I I probably wouldn't have
believed because I knew there was a
problem certainly in the 90s that
political correctness and a desire to
shut up people with offensive opinions
was there and that was that was obvious
to me but the idea that it's it as bad
as it is I have to actually I've been
working at fire now for nine years and
the kind of cases that come in that the
kind of things that can get you in
trouble on a campus these days would be
hysterical if they weren't so tragic
universities have to have the utmost
respect for freedom of speech they have
to be able to I think in in Yale's own
language it says it has to allow you to
mention the unmentionable and think the
unthinkable well at the same time at
Yale just this past year the student
government voted for a t-shirt making
fun of Harvard that quoted F scott
Fitzgerald the quote was in my opinion
all Harvard men are sissies the full
quote is comma like I used to be but
they took the in my opinion all Harvard
men are sissies I'll put it on a t-shirt
with we agree then this is for the Yale
Harvard football game and you know a
little nerdy a little highbrow using a
really anachronistic word that very few
people take seriously and because one
student claimed that this was actually a
slur that [ __ ] was actually a slur they
banned the student
from actually having once again f scott
Fitzgerald quote at a school that
promises that you should be allowed to
think the unthinkable and mention in the
unmentionable f scott Fitzgerald was a
bridge too far that very same year a
author was trying to publish a book
called the cartoons that shook the world
through Yale University Press it's a
book about the Mohammed carp cartoon his
controversy just shortly before it
actually came out Yale University itself
intervened and Ferrand decided that the
author could not have pictures of
Muhammad in a book about the Mohammed
cartoons any other really egregious
cases that come to mind well sure there
was a decision that was just handed down
in a case that we've been involved in
for years this involves a student who
was protesting a parking garage for
environmental reasons and when the
university president found out about
this he called the the student into his
office to harangue him for writing this
op-ed so the student made a collage of
what what the president had said the
president had had pathetically referred
to this parking garage as his legacy
so he made a collage call it referring
to it as the President sakurai Memorial
parking garage that it showed smoke and
Asthma and bulldozers and all what all
he thought and he put it on Facebook
they used this the president used this
as an excuse to kick the student out of
school as a clear and present danger the
professor's own words the good news is
that the court just found that because
he denied the students due process
rights the president can be held
personally liable for damages against
the student who did this and this should
actually this should serve as a warning
to administrators across the country who
think that they can with impunity punish
speech they don't like the law is
incredibly clear they can't what is what
is it about these university
administrators they seem to be among the
most spineless people and harm is a
self-selection thing where they're
attracted to this line of business or do
they are they created like once they
enter that what would be the horrible
repercussions for them if they actually
did stand up for free speech well what's
going on with administrators is a puzzle
and it's very much a mixed bag I I
completely have met
administrators who are actually good on
these issues and I think the most of the
administrators are actually just not
being active enough to defend student
rights but then you have the one of the
one of the kinds of problem at
administrators you have are the
Crusaders the the ones that actually
think that it's their job as for example
at University of Delaware as residents
life to save the souls and psyches of
their students all 7,000 students were
subjected to what they what the resident
life called a treatment that was this
completely comprehensive indoctrination
program that included floor meetings in
which you had to stand on one side of
the room if you had one opinion on a
political issue on one side if you had
on the other basically being a public
shaming of students for the wrong points
of view and even creepier where you had
one on one mandatory one-on-one meetings
with your RA to discuss what races and
sexes you would date a female student
who objected to this actually who said
none of your damn business she was
written up refer for a potential
punishment what is the big picture in
all this how many roughly how many
schools have speech codes how bad is it
in broad terms this is actually good
news of the nearly three hundred schools
that we rate only 71% of them have what
we call red light speech codes
that's laughably unconstitutional or
would be unconstitutional at a public
college that's good news because in
previous years and the ratings all done
by the same person we've gotten as high
as 79 percent all of this all of these
speech codes are somewhat perversely
done in the name of education that
teaching students how to be civil and
teaching students how to how to be
respectful intolerant the but what
you're missing students about is is
about what their rights actually are and
when these speech coats are everywhere
you start talking to students and they
just assume they can't have a
controversial opinion so they just avoid
talking about controversial things in a
lot of cases students are internalizing
the values of censorship as actually
things that good people do that and I
find that personally terrifying and and
if you really understand what's at stake
when you when you limit freedom of
speech that when you understand that our
entire intellectual system going far
beyond just the scientific method
depends on open exchange of ideas and
and and thought experiments then you you
go there ready to battle but not just
the abuses of law but the but the the
weirdly warp mentality that puts
censorship on the side of the angels and
free speech on the side of the devil's
it's completely reversed
are there any schools that consistently
over the years defend free expression um
you know it's funny I I usually would
say Penn State's been pretty good about
a Graham Spanier has been pretty good at
Penn State but we're just releasing a
video right now about a case where there
was a student who is making art a Jewish
student was making art that was critical
of radical Islam and talking about
Palestinian terrorism against Israelis
and his his art was was banned because a
professor claimed it didn't foster
democratic dialogue and that it violated
the university code it's it's amazing
how mental gymnastics people have to do
to justify censorship
I was happy though that Graham Spanier
became involved in the case quickly and
said no no no we're definitely gonna run
this art but then I found out that
actually they never did they publicly
said that they would run the art and
then they never did and another school I
think considered what was about to run
it but then they canceled it for for the
justification being for fear of
terrorist reprisal when there'd been no
threats against the art it was actually
a professor at Penn State University who
just didn't like the politics of the
student in in this case it can be really
heartbreaking sometimes because freedom
of speech is a beautiful idea and it
does foster and in my opinion personal
growth and all you have to do is deal
with the factors sometimes going to hear
things that you think are ignorant or
simply that challenge your worldview and
that's not such a that that's not such a
big price to pay in my opinion
you